à présent on va parler du disque Viny
qui est revenu à la mode depuis quelques
temps et ça dure en 2022 il s'est vendu
plus de 5 millions de vinyle en France
soit environ trois fois plus qu'en 2016
dimanche à tour avait lieu la 40e
édition de la bourse au disque de Radio
Béton à MAM Aurélie Renaud a rencontré
ses fans du 33 tours et les commerçants
qui se sont spécialisés dans le domaine
Nirvana Bob Marley Johnny ch 50000
vinyes prêt à être posé sur la platine
de quoi rassasier les amateurs et les
collectionneurs c'est un bel objet tout
simplement et puis ça fait rêver ça
rappelle les souvenirs et vous avez
combien de Viny à la maison je le dirais
pas en maquette aujourd'hui c'est
principalement les bandes originales de
film et les les disques de de hard rock
au niveau des BO vous cherchez quoi mais
surtout les films années 80 90 bonne
pioche ce client repart avec le 33 tours
des grimlins pour 15 € des vinyles il y
en a pour tous les prix de 5 à plusieurs
milliers d'euros les clients sont pour
la plupart ici des quadras ou des Quinas
avec des demandes précises
essentiellement rock voilà un petit peu
blouses un petit peu jazz mais surtout
une galette noire et brillante et des
pochettes que l'on expose comme des
œuvres d'art ces dernières sont parfois
pourvu de poster et de livrés pour les
adeptes la pochette du disque permet de
construire sa culture musicale derrière
il y a tous les artistes les musiciens
qui sont crédités et donc on va courir
peut-être t guitariste ce guitariste là
on va le retrouver peut-être sur un
autre groupe on va dire ah mais c'était
bien ce qu'il avait fait donc je vais
peut-être aussi me laisser tenter par
cet album là et qui dit vinil dit
platine dans cette boutique de la rue de
Suède à tour on en vend plus d'une
centaine chaque année les prix aussile
entre 50 et 2000 €. vous allez avoir le
méloman qui a toujours une platine Viny
et qui a envie sans cesse d'évoluer et
dans quel cas il va racheter des
platines vinyes et mais vous avez aussi
des des jeunes 15 16 17 ans qui
s'équipent avec leur la première platine
Viny qui viennent l'acheter ici conseil
du professionnel ne jetez jamais votre
vieille platine un grand dépoussiérage
et un changement de diamant suffiront à
lui donner une seconde
vie